Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Meric Aydonat
Her şey çok net olsun.
Bugün, benim babamın ölümünün
dokuzuncu yıl dönümü
ve her şey çok net olsun da;
babamın ölmeden önce
söylediği son söz
ama söyleyemedi de yazabildi.
Çünkü ikinci beyin kanamasını
geçiriyordu o sırada.
Hastanedeyiz, sekiz gün geçmiş
ilk kanamanın üzerinden.
İlk yedi gün çok güzeldi ama son yirmi
dört saatte bazı sorunlarımız vardı.
Ve o sorunlar dolayısıyla
bir saat önce onu
tomografiye çıkarttılar ve indirdiler.
Odadayız, konuşmak istiyor
ağzını açıyor ama konuşamıyor.
Gözlerimiz dolu dolu
ve aklıma bir şekilde geldi dedim ki;
baba yazabilir misin?
Başını salladı ve bir tane
kalem bulduk, verdik kalem.
İşte orada bir tane
hastane broşürü buldum,
boş bir yerini buldu o da ve oraya
"bir muz istiyorum" yazdı.
Şimdi babam da muzu çok severdi.
Hemen arkamı döndüm
ve dedim ki;
bir muz getirir misiniz?
Falan bilmem ne.
Ve akabinde bir baktım ki babam
hala elini oynatıyor orada.
Tekrar götürdüm broşürü oraya ve
‘’her şey çok net olsun’’ yazdı.
Şimdi;
büyük ihtimalle, ikinci
beyin kanaması onun beynindeki,
herhalde bir algı merkezi mi artık,
orada bir baskı yapıyordu,
baskı yapıyor olmalı ki;
bir şeyleri, algıları,
herhalde flulaşmıştı.
Dolayısıyla o da her şey
çok net olsun yazdı.
Dolayısıyla bunun arkasında
ulvi bir anlam aramıyorum.
Ama bir anlam arıyorum.
Ve diyorum ki belki de
hayatı yavaşlatmanın yolu,
hayatı netleştirmekten geçiyor,
hayata olan bakış açımızı
netleştirmekten geçiyor.
Dolayısıyla bir iletişimci olarak,
bir masalcı olarak size;
yedi adımda nasıl kendi hayatımı
netleştirdiğimi anlatacağım.
Önce, son beş yılda iki yüzden fazla
konuşma yaptım bir yerlerde
ve bu konuşmaların tamamında
insanları gaza getirdiğimi
yani bir çoğunda insanları
gaza getirdiğimi söylerler.
Bugün aranızdan birçok kişi
eve gittiğinde benden
ya da başkalarından
o motivasyonu almış olacaklar
ve akşam eve hayatlarında
bir şeyleri değiştirmek için,
bir şeylere motive olmak için gidecek.
Ta ki; Whatsapp'tan
bir mesaj gelene kadar.
Aşkım bugün beni niye aramadın
falan diye mesaj gelecek
ve o mesaja cevap
verdiği an bugün yaşadığı
başkalarının deneyimlerinden beslendiği
bütün deneyim üzeri örtülecek.
Çünkü bizim günlük
deneyimlerimizin üzeri,
günlük deneyimlerimiz çok güçlü.
O yüzden başkalarından aldığımız
deneyimlerin üzerini örtüyor.
Şimdi size basit bir hikaye
anlatmak istiyorum.
Bu anlattığımı desteklemek adına.
Orta okuldayım,
orta ikinci sınıftayım...
Bir resim hocamız var.
Bir kadın, elinde bir vazoyla
geldi o gün derse ve vazoyu
öğretmen masasının
tam ortasına koydu.
Ve dedi ki; işte herkes
bulunduğu yerden baktığı bakış açısıyla
bu vazoyu çizsin, kara kalem.
Ben de açtım beyaz bir sayfa,
aldım elime kalemi
ve şöyle şu şekilde, bir çizik attım.
Sadece vazonun hatlarını
netleştirmek istemiştim oysa ki.
Hoca meğerse o sırada benim
kağıdıma bakıyormuş ve dedi ki,
tırnakları da böyle şeydi,
inceydi böyle kulağımı çekti
ve dedi ki;
— Picasso mu sandın ya
sen kendini, falan dedi.
Tabi bugün olsa birisi bana bunu dese,
derim ki;
— Ne yani kardeşim,
Picasso yedi yaşındayken,
hiç mi vazo çizmedi? Ki çizdi bu arada.
Hiç mi çizmedi?
Dolayısıyla bu benim tarzım olamaz mı?
Ben tek çizgide vazo çizen
bir insan olamaz mıyım? derdim
ama o gün diyemedim.
Onun istediği gibi çizmek zorunda kaldım.
Şimdi size bu hikayeyi anlattım.
Bu hikaye bazılarınızı eğlenceli geldi.
Akşam ortamlarda başkalarına
satabileceğiniz bir hikaye olabilir.
Aralarınızdan bazıları hatta belki bir
öğretmen kendine bir anlam çıkartıp,
o anlamı hayatına bir şekilde
embedebilir ya da kalabilir
ve hayatına devam edebilir
ama bu basit deneyim,
bu basit hikaye benim hayatımı değiştirdi.
O günden beridir hiç kimse bana
neyi nasıl yapacağımı söyleyemez
ve eğer kendi tarzımla
yapmıyorsam bir işi,
hiç kimse bana yaptıramaz o işi.
Dolayısıyla benim hayatı
netleştirmekten anladığım,
hayatı basitleştirmek.
Kendi deneyimimi size anlatıyorum
ancak bu deneyimden,
kendiniz bir şekilde beslenmelisiniz
diye düşünüyorum.
Dolayısıyla her şey çok net olsun
ve her şeyin çok net olması için
ben bir kendimce yedi adımdan ilerledim.
Bu adımlara da hayatımda ihtiyacım
vardı çünkü kaosun ortasındaydım.
Ve o kaosu artık daha fazla
yaşamak istemediğimi fark ettim.
Çünkü hayat çok kısaydı.
Çünkü babam 50 yaşında
ölmüştü topu topu.
Dolayısıyla ben bu dünyaya
toplu konutlarda yaşamak için gelmedim.
Bu dünyaya 10-20 yıl mortgage
ödeyeyim bilmem ne diye gelmedim.
Bu dünyaya işte başkaları
zenginleşsin, ben fakirleşeyim,
işte sonra hayatım boyunca
borç içinde yaşayayım
sonra da beyin kanamasından
öleyim diye gelmedim.
Babamı çok seviyorum ama
ben dünyaya babam için de gelmedim
ya da babam olmak için de gelmedim.
Dolayısıyla her şeyin
çok net olmasını istiyorum
dolayısıyla size de
bunu anlatmak istiyorum.
Bir;
yalan söylemeyi bıraktım.
Eskiden yalan söylüyordum.
İşte iş almak için yalan söylerdik,
müşteriyi idare etmek için
yalan söylerdim.
İşte hayatımda sahip olduğum şeyleri
daha iyi göstermek için yalan söylerdim,
yalancı değildim ama
yalan söylüyordum sürekli olarak.
Ve yalanlarımı bir şekilde
o hikâyeleri birbirine bağlarken
ciddi bir zaman harcıyordum.
Ta ki hayatıma birisi girdi.
Bir sene boyunca bir
iş ortaklığı yaptım birisiyle;
dünya güzeli bir adam,
dünya güzeli bir herif
ama hayatının çok kötü bir
döneminde
karşılaşmış olmalıyız ki onunla
tam bir sene boyunca
herkese yalan söyledi.
Ve yalanları o kadar böyle
birbirine bağlıydı ki
iki gün önce söylediği bir şeyi inanarak,
iki gün sonra başka şekilde de söylüyordu.
En son onun yanından ben ayrıldım.
Ben ayrılırken bana da çok yalan söyledi
ve dedim ki ben kesinlikle
böyle olmamalıyım.
İtibarım ve inandırıcılığımı bu şekilde
kaybetmem doğru değil dedim.
O gün yalan söylemeyi bıraktım.
Şu an bir müşterim geliyor, diyor ki;
— Fatih bu iş neden yetişmedi?
Yalan söylemiyorum, doğruyu söylüyorum.
Müşteri sağ olsun affediyor.
Çok basit çok net ve hayatımı
netleştirmek için bıraktım onu.
İkincisi; hayır demeyi öğrendim.
Eskiden evetçiydim ben.
Evet abi, tamam abi, hallederiz abi,
(Alkışlar)
geliyorum abi tamamen bu.
Ve bu evet hayatını
yaşamak çok zor bir hayat.
Sürekli bir keşmekeşin
içine sürükleniyorsun,
çünkü hiç kimseyi kırmıyorsun
hiç kimseye hayır demiyorsun
direk devam ediyorsun.
Sonra hayır demeyi öğrendim
ama insanlara direkt olarak
hayır demiyorum.
İşte, Fatih şu işi yapabilir misin?
Hayır, desem bir daha bana iş vermez ki.
Mesela bir müşteri geliyor diyor ki;
— Fatih diyor bizim
şöyle bir projemiz var,
bu işi size yaptırmak istiyoruz,
sizin ajansınıza yaptırmak
istiyoruz diyor.
Şimdi hayır desem bir daha iş vermez.
Ne diyorum ben de;
— Abi ya bu aralar elimiz gerçekten
çok yoğun, dolayısıyla bir işi
hakkıyla yapabilmek için
elimizin rahat olmasını isterdim.
Siz bence bu işi başkasına yaptırırsanız,
eminim daha kaliteli bir iş alırsınız
çünkü biz şu an bunu yapamayız.
Şimdi bakın hayır demeden
hayır dedim aslında.
Bu aynı zamanda bir
itibarda getiriyor yanında,
neden?
Çünkü bu adam sadece
kaliteli iş yapıyor diyor müşteri
bir daha geliyor, bir daha iş veriyor.
Dolayısıyla netleştiriyor iş hayatımı.
Size üçüncü maddeden bahsetmeden
önce sizden bir şey rica edeceğim:
Herkes sağ elini kaldırabilir mi ?
Göremiyorum ama.
Şimdi biraz daha yukarı kaldırın,
biraz daha yukarı kaldırın,
şimdi kaldırabildiğiniz kadar kaldırın.
Okey.
Neden kimse ayağa kalkmadı?
(Gülüşmeler)
Düşünce sistemimi değiştirdim.
Şimdi ezberimi kendi ezberimizi
bozmamız gerektiğini düşünüyorum hayatta
ve bana da bu testi yaptıklarında
sizin aranızda 30-40 kişinin
aklından geçen,
benim de aklımdan geçmişti;
ayağa kalkmam lazım.
Ama maalesef bize, hayatımızın
her yerinde öğrenilmiş
bir çaresizlik veriyorlar.
Mesela ailemiz veriyor bunu,
okul veriyor bunu,
medya veriyor bunu.
Siyasi arena bunu körüklüyor.
Ekonomik koşullar bunu tetikliyor,
bilmem ne, bilmem ne…
Mesela hepinizin başına gelmiştir;
aman kızım devlete kapağı at,
aman oğlum üniversiteyi bitir,
aman çocuğum para kazanmadan
başarılı saymam.
İşte askerlik yapmayana
kız vermem bilmem ne.
Şimdi ben kendi hayatıma bakıyorum.
Ben üniversite mezunu değilim.
Atıldım, devamsızlıktan atıldım.
İngilizceyi kendim öğrendim
ve birinci sınıf bir İngilizcem,
ana dilim gibi İngilizcem var.
Otuz yaşımda evlendim.
Ondan sonra sıfırdan iş kurdum.
Bana dediler ki;
para kazanamazsın, kazandım.
Dediler ki, bu işi satamazsın, sattım.
Dediler ki rakibine hayatta satamazsın,
gittim rakibime sattım.
Ve altı yılda on milyon liraya
yakın ciro yaratmış olmama,
cari yaratmış olmama rağmen;
ne hala kendi evim var,
ne hala kendi arabam var.
Hala kiralık evde oturuyorum.
Hala kiralık araba kullanıyorum.
Bunların hiçbirinin beni
bir şekilde içine çekmesine
izin vermedim.
Bunu nasıl yaptım biliyor musunuz?
Kendi ezberimi bozmaya çalışarak yaptım.
O gün bana da o testi yaptılar,
kalkmak istedim siyah koyun
olmak istedim ama olamadım.
Sonra hayatımın ne kadar değerli olduğunu
ve ne kadar kısa bir
zamanım olduğunu gördüm.
Ve siyah koyun olmayı seçtim.
Kaderimi kendim yazmayı seçtim.
Dolayısıyla da ortaya bu çıktı.
Dört;
Disiplinli yaşamayı öğrendim.
Sabah onda işe gidilmez.
Eğer bir iş sahibiysen,
saygıyı hak ettiğini düşünüyorsan,
saat onda işe gidilmez.
Biz yedi haziran seçim
kampanyasını yaparken,
sabah saat altıda uyanıyordum.
Yedide ofiste oluyordum.
Yedi ile sekiz arasında
planlama yapıyordum.
O günün planlamasını yapıyordum.
Sekiz ile dokuz arasında o planlamayı
ekibime mail olarak atıyordum.
İdari maillerimi atıyordum.
Ve dokuzda net bir şekilde
işime başlıyordum
ve kontrol altında tutuyordum her şeyi.
Çünkü öyle bir iş yapıyordum o zamanlar.
Şimdi bu disipline şu an asıl hepsinden,
her zamandan daha çok ihtiyacım var,
neden?
Çünkü artık evden çalışıyorum.
Artık ofisim yok.
Herkes evden çalışıyor,
benim çalıştığım insanlar.
Ve evden çalışırken alt katıma bir tane,
bizim evimizin alt katına,
kendime bir tane ofis yaptım.
Sabah saat sekizde uyanıyorum.
Aynen mesaiye gidermiş gibi,
eşofmanla falan değil
nasıl mesaiye gidiyorsam,
onları giyiyorum ve
bilgisayarımın başına oturuyorum.
Akşam beşe kadar işimi gücümü yapıyorum.
Bu disiplini hayatımın
her yanında uygulayabileyim
ve netleşsin her şey diye.
Beş;
İktisat yapmaya başladım.
Şimdi disiplinli bir şekilde
çalışıyor olabilirim.
Dolayısıyla da aslında
ihtiyaç duyduğumuz ya da
istediğimiz her şeyi
satın alabiliyoruz, çok şükür.
Ama; eşimde burada, kendisi de söylesin
ben bir teknoloji manyağıyım.
Bir sürü teknolojik cihaz almayı severim.
Taa ki iki üç senedir artık
almıyorum bu teknolojik cihazları.
Eğer ihtiyacım varsa
şuna göre belirliyorum.
Üç saatte yaptığım bir işi bir saatte
yapmamı sağlıyorsa o cihazı alıyorum.
Ya da dört tane cihazla yaptığım işi,
bir tane cihazla yapabiliyorsam
o cihazı alıyorum.
Onun dışında hiçbir şey almıyorum.
Bunun yanında ayakkabıydı,
giysiydi bilmem ne
bunların hiçbirini almıyorum.
Düşünsenize şimdi kampanya
bir alana ikincisi bedava,
yüzde elli indirim.
İhtiyacım, spor ayakkabıya
yoksa sırf fiyatı ucuz diye,
hiç spor ayakkabı alınır mı kardeşim?
Diye soruyorum ben kendime.
Ve son iki senede aldığım
tek ayakkabı da bu yani.
Onun dışında da başka
hiçbir şey almıyorum.
İktisat yapıyorum.
Bu arada,
(Gülüşmeler)
bakıyorum, bakıyorum, bakıyorum...
Genç insanlara bakıyorum,
üç kuruş para kazanıyorlar.
Maalesef böyle durum
ve üzülüyorum da bu duruma
ama böyle inanılmaz
çalgılı çengili düğünler,
muazzam paralar harcıyorlar
o düğünlere, evlerinde yok yok.
Bizim evimizde beş sene
önce aldığımız LED var.
3D, bilmem ne bir sürü
bir şeyler var evlerinde.
Şimdi ne ihtiyacım var ki;
evdeki televizyon
yetmiyor mu diyorum ben?
Ama onların evinde yok yok
böyle ve hayatlarında,
evlilik hayatlarının, en mutlu
olmaları gerektiği
ilk beş senesinde sırf borç halindeler.
Hiç borçta netlik olur mu ya?
Hayatı yani hiç borç yüküyle
yaşanır mı diyorum.
Böyle bir kaos sıkıntılı değil mi diyorum.
Dolayısıyla biz de o kaosun
içinde çıkmanın yolunu,
şehirden uzaklaşmakta bulduk.
Altı;
Şehir hayatı bizi bence
yaratıcı insanların,
hayal gücünü öldürüyor.
Bence şehir hayatı
çalışkan insanları tembelleştiriyor,
bence tutarlı insanları dağıtıyor.
Şehir hayatı bizi sürekli
olarak içine çekiyor.
Her gün mutsuz insanlardan besleniyoruz.
Her gün, iletişim kurduğumuz insanlarla,
trafikte falan iletişim kuruyoruz
ve bunlar bizim hatırımızda kalıyor,
bizi besliyor geriliyoruz
bilmem ne bir şey.
Diyorum ki ne yapıyorum ?
Eşimin itelemesiyle Bodrum'a
taşınma fırsatı bulduk.
Hakikaten dedik ki yeter bu bize.
Sonra bir baktık ki aslında
diğer maddede de destekleyen
bir durum var ortada.
Annem geçenlerde İstanbul'da
kardeşimin evine,
mutfak masrafı yapmak için
pazara gitmiş diyor ki bana;
Bodrum’da 80 liraya
aldığımız meyve sebzeyi
İstanbul'da 220 liraya aldım diyor.
Ben de diyorum ki içimden o sırada
ben İstanbul'da yaşayacak kadar
zengin değilim demek ki diyorum.
Çünkü benim zenginliğim;
işte akşam bahçemizde oturdum,
bir tane mandalina soydum, yedim.
Daha ötesi yok ki bunun.
İhtiyaç duymadığım ayakkabıyı almıyorsam,
demek ki mandalina seviyorsam
mandalina yemeliyim değil mi?
Daha bir altın mandalinası var mı bunun?
Altın çileği var ama altın
mandalinası var mı bilmiyorum.
Dolayısıyla şehirden uzaklaştım.
Ve yedi; ki bence hepsinden önemlisi
kitap okumaya başladım.
(Alkışlar)
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Kitap okumaya başladım
ve benim o cesarete sahip olmamın
en önemli şeyi;
şehir hayatından uzaklaşmakta,
artık buramıza gelmişti.
Ama kitap okumaya da ihtiyacım vardı.
Babamdan bahsettim size.
Benim babam kitap hastasıydı çok okuyordu
ve başkalarının evinde
vitrinlerde süs eşyaları varken
Ben üç buçuk yaşında okumayı öğrenmişim.
Yedi yaşından yirmi beş yaşına kadar da,
her gece yatmadan önce
bir saat kitap okudum.
Bu 25 yaşında sosyal medya
diye bir şeyle tanıştım.
İşte Twitter, Facebook,
bilmem ne, bir sürü içerik akıyor.
İşte haberler, trendler,
gündem, bilmem ne
o, bu ve her gün 1,5-2 saat bunu
okuduğumu fark ediyorum.
Ve bu bir illüzyon aslında.
Kitap okumanın yerine
geçmiyor internet okumaları.
O bir çöp yani.
Bir kitap okumak
çünkü bir deneyim katıyor,
bir bilgi katıyor bir şey katıyor.
Kitabın sayfasını çevirmek bile,
insanın ikinci bir duyusuna hitap ettiği
için, akılda kalıcılığı arttırıyormuş.
Oysa biz internette ne yapıyoruz?
Aşağı çekiyoruz.
Dolayısıyla bundan 2-3 sene önce
kitap okumaya daha fazla,
eskisi kadar, zaman ayırmayı
istediğimi fark ettim.
Ancak İstanbul’da yaşayıp da
araba kullanıp,
kitap okumaya çalışmak
o zaman mümkün değil.
Dolayısıyla benim Bodrum'a taşınma
cesaretini göstermemin,
ikinci ana sebebi kitap okumaya
daha fazla vakit ayırmaktı.
Ve şunu da fark ettim,
ve Bodrum'a gittikten
sonra şunu yapıyoruz artık,
her gün eşimle 1-1,5 saat
evde kitap okuyoruz.
Televizyonda Survivor mı izleyelim yani?
Kitap okuyoruz.
O yüzden ve İstanbul’a her hafta bir iki
gün gidiyorum işte uçakta 1,5 saat,
bekleme salonunda 1 saat,
metroda bilmem ne falan kitap okuyorum.
Her İstanbul’a gidiş dönüşüm bir kitap.
Haftada da toplam bir kitap iki kitap,
100 kitap yılda demek.
Bu 100 kitaba zaman ayırabiliyorum
ve şunu fark ettim; eğer ben
buna zaman ayırabiliyorsam
insanlar da buna zaman ayırabilir.
Dolayısıyla kitap kulübü
diye bir şey kurdum.
Dünyada da yokmuş böyle bir örneği.
Baktık falan böyle.
İnsanlar da kitap okusun
bizimle birlikte diye, bir kulüp kurduk.
Şimdi size babamdan bahsettim.
Babam da hayatı boyunca;
hayatının, erişkin hayatının
yarısında medyacılık,
yarısında kitapçılık yaptı.
Benim de şimdiye kadarki
en büyük başarım medyada,
şu anda yapıyor olduğum işte kitap işi.
Dolayısıyla en başta demiştim ya size,
ulvi bir anlam aramıyorum demiştim ama
babamın son sözü de
madem her şey çok net olsundu
ve ben 34 yaşında babamın sözüne geldim.
Ve aslında da bir yandan da babamın
adımlarını izleyip harekete geçmişim.
Öyleyse belki de bu sözün altında:
"Her şey çok net olsun" un altında
ulvi bir anlam aramam
gerektiğini fark ettim.
Sizin de hayatınız da
umarım her şey çok net olur.
Harikasınız hepiniz.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz için.
(Alkışlar)